how are you Chris
dan this is Marv Albert Chris is very
busy Wow let me see if I can yeah like
Chris Chris has a designated
spokesperson there its Marv Albert and I
hold a second loan sure if he wants to
come on now don't tell me I don't have
the best office in the world when Marv
Albert man that's pretty good I I
thought about you I'm watching Indiana
basketball last night and I'm noticing
the shorts are getting a little shorter
I don't know if you've noticed this
because the Fab five gave us the baggy
shorts what do you think is is this
cyclical where we're going to go back to
the short shorts you know I'm with you
then I think it is cyclical I think the
fact that you know everybody has to kind
of have their own style and if it's been
done one way then you know I think the
normal reaction is to go the opposite so
my thing is as long as long as you have
game hopefully you do that hopefully
take a shower after and wash up and keep
the area clean because it's not good
keeping that area bound and tightened up
down there a lot playing the game so
long as they're having fun loans you
have game you can definitely create your
own snob but could you imagine the Fab
Five having short shorts Jonathan
Johnson no I mean the whole thing for us
is that for me personally the reason why
I wore long shorts was I grew up playing
in the park and I had to cut up my jeans
and then we had changed shorts and they
were longer and they were comfortable
you can breathe you know you might as
well just go out there and pretty soon
God's just gonna start playing in a
tight under their shirts and shorts and
not even put their shorts on if guys
want to do that I guess that's the new
style Europeans did is going from suits
to uniforms but hopefully they just have
games and they're doing because you have
game like John Stockton you're wearing
tight shorts you look like a idiot
was John Stockton dirty to you
I was going to toughest-ever plating his
there we had a series on the playoffs it
was our first series in Sarah Leno and
we were playing against Utah great
comment on the Stockton and I felt that
our team was in all of them we were
younger until I told coach out of them
before the game I said on the first play
of the game
I'm gonna lay stockings ass out I said
trust me the first game we just need to
do it like you know they're they're
prepared for everything that's coming
they don't expect it either lay him out
on the screen I'm talking about I laid
him on the best screams I ever did got
my shoulder kind of in that head area to
make it a little dirty he pops up off
the ground
patched me on the button says my screen
do you know how you know what I mean so
yeah he's he was one of the toughest
guys and I loved it too after that game
we would play him in the playoffs and I
would make rookies wait on the bus and I
would say watch the bad in the world
Paulo and they like what do you mean I
think I'm gonna talk about like his cars
and all this and John Stockton would
come to the game literally in a minivan
Papa's coming there and bust us up so
yeah he's a bad man and he would show up
and he would probably have a plaid shirt
on and you know jeans or something
his hair parted neatly on the side look
he'd be so unassuming he'd be a guy
they'd probably check his ID in other
arenas oh you thought he was you know
coming straight out of Catholic Church
well the kids up there you know lighting
the candles or where you thought you
definitely he was his basket man it was
but he knew that and he he knew that
being unassuming was part of was part of
his swagger so he knew that and he used
that to his advantage too he's Chris
Webber joining us on loan from TNT but
who was the craziest guy you faced the
crazies got a plate where was burning
Maxwell yes that was fun every day that
was fun every day because he practiced
as hard as he played in games and so as
long as learning knew that you support
him and you had his back as a friend
evanka love offered but some of the
things and Jay will I got a pitch a
wheel up there Jay will probably occur
his funniest guy that I've ever been
around what I miss about J well it's not
necessarily being on the court it's
going to the mall and being in the food
court with them and hanging out because
he's a person that man just just he's
just crazy West Virginia cat there's a
lot of fun playing with him could he
play now
Kayson wind yes yes yes he is he is by
far the best player not in the NBA that
play and hold no course how old is he
now he pulled it 43 Jason may have just
turned 39 or 40 because I'm watching him
he does he just turned 40 so I'm
watching him in these pickup games I
know it's a pickup game but he looks he
looks great if he didn't have that he
probably would be playing now like he's
like a guy like you know all due respect
to the great Pistol Pete um one of the
sad tragic parts about Pistol Pete life
is one of the things I admire is that he
died on the court you don't want to die
over this you know and aged forty passed
away yeah and so it's shorten the time
but if I believe it is two people have
been lifted been 80 he's about on the
court and I believe that about Jason if
I don't put pressure I'm going to say
this but I'm not putting pressure on his
kid I'm not it's not about how good his
kid could be you're LeBrons kid it's not
about that but today if you google his
son Jackson his son might be better than
him at six years old I mean he looks
like a little man out there he looks
like a looks like a little man out there
to waiting plays and so Jason is
somebody man
he loves football basketball he's just
the sports fanatic if he had a daughter
she'd be the best in volleyball like
he's Jason's at sports 24 hours a day so
it was always fun to hang around him
talk sport his son Jackson is gonna be
bad too Russell Westbrook speaking of
bad bad in a good way
I I mentioned a Reggie Miller I said if
Westbrook and the Thunder if he averages
a triple-double and they are above 500
does that make him the most valuable the
most by that's a tough one because you
still have lebron you still have what
durant has done but being that it has a
habit of since the sixties 50
years ago I would say that he definitely
has to be up there I would want to see
their record if he's over 500 like they
say if they make the playoffs I couldn't
argue could not argue against that when
what we're talking about what everyone
else is just going I know you got to go
thanks I didn't mean to hold up the the
production meeting there and of course
you don't want to make more of Albert
mad yeah well you know no Marv is the
man which is he such a great guy to work
with it's like a blessing to work he's
you know I didn't I didn't graduate
journalism school I didn't I didn't you
know Judas's so you know from the fact
of him right opens to him really
focusing on my career the same with dick
Stockton's the same with Kevin Harlan
and then I'm just I'm blessed to be
doing something I love and it had the
best teacher same with Reggie Miller I
mean he's the guy learned to do research
from in these gangs so I appreciate the
whole team this does maybe better and so
it's a blessing to be here Turner doing
my thing
can you still dunk oh yeah baby oh yeah
I'm gonna dunk Allah until I die summer
I have the dunk at least once I don't
anymore I just retired because my 16
year old nephew Colton almost beat me
and it took everything in line beat him
so I'm not gonna let him beat me I'm
gonna quit now while I'm undefeated so
I'm officially retired from life's path
well I don't know I wonder too bad I
watched Reggie shoot last year and he
was shooting from three and he had jeans
and a sweater on and he was killing it
Reggie Miller can still shoot as well as
anybody in the game
think about this Dan I have this idea I
want to know what you think okay I think
that after we have the three-point
contest in the NBA right we let Kevin
Hart shoot we let all people that
haven't shoot these concepts yeah I
think we need to do is do the regular
three-point contest have a winner
and let's say Steph Curry wins then we
go get guys like Craig I just tell curry
Reggie Miller
Larry Bird because I think it was show
that the game doesn't get oh you know
your jump shot never can get old and I'd
like you said Reggie still one of
three-point shooters it'll be
interesting to see them bring out the
old shooters and every year after you
have the three-point champ to let them
shoot against them with a different rag
just numbers but I think it was show
like the skill set never leaves these
guys I mean you think about
Paxton you think about even occur I
think it would just be interesting for
people to see them come against others
because a fatigue and everything doesn't
come into it like class so I'm pushing
that we have some veterans shoot threes
in a contest in in some of the NBA
all-star games to come well what I'd
like to view
I'd have Steph Curry coupled with Steve
Kerr so you had teams of new and retired
so Steph shoots the first rack Kerr gets
the next one Steph got the next one
courage got the next one so the older
guys only shooting two racks and then
Steph is going to shoot three racks what
do you think I love it except I'd put
stuff with Dale and it would be it'd be
wonderful I mean this is Dale I still
think their lives up there with which
stuff maybe not as nice but I still
think he could shoot with him but I
definitely I definitely like the I think
it would be good man because you can
just show the basketball and you know
the shot always stays the same but I
think it'd be interesting it'd be much
better than those old old-timer games
you got got hey have fun tonight and
it's always great talk to you Chris
thanks for joining us thank you very
much all right that's Chris Weber the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]